one of our favorite guests period
regardless of any of the sports that we
talk about
uh from espn uh one of the best nba
insiders in the game brian windhorst
back on the show how are you brian
i'm okay rich thank you yeah no thanks
for for joining let's let's jump in with
both feet here uh about james harden
and your colleague tim mcmahon's story
um you know obviously it's somebody else
who wrote it
uh did anything that uh come out of that
story
leap out at you surprise you or
something this is this is industry known
what's been going on with houston and
and hardin
brian well tim mcmahon is a is a bulldog
reporter who is completely fearless so
he he reports these types of stories all
the time although
uh this one is pretty special um
it's it's not it's not unusual you know
star
treatment in the nba um uh especially
over the last decade
for star players to dictate practice
schedules to dictate
travel schedules i mean i remember when
i first started covering the nba
teams flew out after every game that
they were if they were on the road they
traveled after every night they didn't
care if it was
january in los angeles and your next
stop was salt lake city you traveled and
that is no longer the norm and and star
players have driven that um
you know lebron uh back in his first go
around in cleveland was getting
uh changes in travel schedule that is
not unusual there's
certain star treatment that has
certainly been paid to kawhi leonard uh
by the la clippers so
um those stories um really aren't
surprising i think what tim is pointing
out
is that you know the rockets really uh
were not just giving james those special
privileges but really letting him
dictate
over major decisions that happened in
the roster
and you know sometimes you know you know
look lebron james wanted anthony davis
he pretty much was willing to
he made it pretty clear as well to trade
the whole team for anthony davis which
they did
it turned out pretty good um it's not
unique to hardin but um
it hasn't worked out um for harden
he you know while he has been
spectacular over the last six or seven
years
he hasn't delivered at the highest level
in the playoffs
and now the rockets uh situation is
very badly eroded and hardened is a root
cause
and you have to assess the collateral
damage from that
and it makes for a complicated situation
and more importantly rich
if you're out there and you want it you
want to trade for james harden you are
seeing this story you probably had a
pretty good idea of this anyway right
but you are seeing this story you are
learning about this you are looking at a
guy who is not
dedicated to his conditioning you're
looking at a guy who
turned out a 100 million dollar
extension and then didn't dedicate to
his conditioning
who is putting his team his teammates
and his coach at a horrible position
and he's basically saying okay come
trade for me it's a
it's pushing the limits of the star
power mba pretty much to its nth degree
now you're you're you know i you alluded
to this and
you know it's just like in the nfl too
there really are no secrets i mean
the chattiest bunch of people i've ever
met or is anybody involved in a sports
organization everybody talks to each
other i'm sure
you know most of this stuff was already
known although perhaps
what chris paul and and hardin were
grinding gears about or russell
westbrook in a film room in the bubble
as tim mcmahon was talking about
you know chafing over harden time i
guess and he wasn't there in time for a
film session and demanding it start and
d'antoni's saying if we started we'll
just
start it again when james arrives and so
on and so forth those details might be
first brought to light by this
remarkable story by your colleague tim
mcmahon but
putting it all together the thing that i
took out of it is like would you
even knowing all this uh go ahead and
trade for a guy
who for whom his uh regimen
uh would absolutely catch up with mid
30s right i mean like
at some point there there has to be a
little bit of slowing of the
uh of the in in between games
frolic right i mean wouldn't that be a
concern
uh for any team that might take on
harden here
yeah especially because he's in a
strange sort of tweener position with
his
contract now we all remember a couple of
years ago when kawhi leonard demanded a
trade he had one year left on his
contract the spurs had
next to no leverage and the trade
package that they got i mean they got a
quality player in
demar derozan but it wasn't the same you
know
trade that you could have made if you
were going to have him for a few years
so he either rockets are not taking
pennies on the dollar for him because
he's got multiple years
having said that it's two years so if
you're going to pay the going rate for
an mvp level player which is probably
all the good young players you've got on
your roster maybe your best player
depending on how the trade works
and potentially two or three first round
draft pace if you're trading you're
mortgaging your future can you do that
with a guy with two years left on his
contract ideally you'd like
for him to extend his contract so that
you know you have a window with him
so he's in that in that sort of zone but
you look at him and you look at the way
he's treated his team
and he now you you have pause he does
have a player option in his contract you
could
sort of split the difference and ask him
to pick up that player option but
you know a contract extension for him
would be paying him 50 million dollars
a year when he's in his mid 30s um
that's a hard pill to to accept right
now and
and so the rockets have a high burden
that they wanted to to to get him in a
trade which
understandably he's been in the top
three or four the mvp rates for the last
half decade and then you have teams that
are going to be worried about that
um i think it's a very complicated trade
to pull off i think they'll get it done
um i think it's going to be a hard mix
you do you think they so when when when
does something like this get done
that's the the question we don't know i
mean i think you know one of the things
that's happened in the last
few months rich is that the 2021
free agent class which at one time
looked pretty damn promising
has essentially vaporized giannis will
not be a part of it
there was a pot i'm not saying that i
thought lebron or anthony davis were
going to move but there was a
possibility
that those guys were going to be free
agents they ended up both signing long
paul george was going to potentially be
available he extended his contract
um you know and even sort of the second
level star players
drew holiday is likely to extend in
milwaukee
uh now that giannis has rudy gobert
who's an attractive player
an extension candidate the only guy out
there of an elite level uh
super elite level free agent is going to
be kawhi
he's not eligible for an extension so
he's going to be a free agent having
said that there's no indication he's
leaving la so if you're a team that was
pinning itself on trying to get a star
player in 2021
you reassess here and say well the star
player may be able to get his james
harden so
um and i do think there's two or three
teams out there who could get into that
into that game whether or not those
teams are going to be on james harden's
list
and whether or not james harden if he
got traded to a place off of his list
would show up and play like kawhi
leonard showed up and played
that's a quite open question for sure
all right so brian windhorst
who are those teams as are are any
are any of the let's start with this are
any of the teams that are on hardin's
wish list a possibility
do you think i think the miami heat are
an interesting possibility pat riley has
long been a guy who's believed in
get me the the highest level talent and
then our system will make it work the
classic example of that
was shaquille o'neal um when he had kind
of washed out uh
his welcome in in la and they got him
into a position where
he was uh he was executing at a very
high level um
and they have the young players the
problem with that is they only have
one draft pick they're currently allowed
to trade which is 2027.
so it's it's hard for them to to give
the draft capital but
you know a young player like tyler hero
being a centerpiece of a trade package
might um be interesting you have the new
york knicks
who have you know a bunch of young
players all of their
draft picks available to them and if you
know if they want to improve rapidly
that's a guy that they could maybe get
um and then you have some sort of for
farther shot teams
which would be a baby a team like the
cleveland cavaliers who
has young players has a bunch of has
extra drastics
i don't think that's where james harden
would want to be but that's the type of
team that could
maybe make an offer uh that that could
get houston interested
um you know and you could go farther
down the list
but i do think that there will be teams
that will make offers when will they
make them
you know we have to see how things play
out brian windhorst here
on the rich eisen show when we had you
on during the summer and we were all
looking over the steering wheel at the
honest decision while we were uh while
the bubble was wrapping up
you said that if giannis doesn't sign
for the super max the nba
might as well just remove that uh that
whole construct from the collective
bargaining agreement that it was created
exactly for a player like this in a
franchise like
milwaukee he is now signed so i'm
assuming
uh two things that i'd love to give you
the floor on one the nba is
breathing a sigh of relief and two there
are a bunch of teams that were hoping
for giannis to leave that are now on to
plan b's long term
uh i'll give you the floor on who those
teams are and what the nba is thinking
right now you know i i know that this
could just sound sort of like a little
bit of a crazy statement but
you want to sign that contract yesterday
you could make the cases the biggest
moment in the bucks franchise
since 1974 when kareem abdul-jabbar
had beef wellington and then looked up
at wayne embry the general manager and
said
hey i want you to trade me he was he'd
won a title there
he had just lost game seven of the
finals
and was a reigning mvp they traded him
to the lakers uh some months later the
bucks have not been back to the final
since
and um for a small market team with an
nba superstar there is no more fragile
relationship
giannis leaving the milwaukee bucks
potentially sets them back a decade or
more or two decades or four decades
you just don't get players like this and
so for you
to make this commitment to give them a
gift and one of the reasons it's a gift
is not just because he's staying with
them
but rich he could have signed this exact
same contract next summer
by doing it now and giving up his
options in free agency
he removes uh incredible amount of
stress that was going to be on the bucks
this season
and it does give the bucks the best
chance to be successful this year
but he gave away something to it he gave
away his optionality
um this is just not something we see in
the modern nba we just haven't seen
players do this um
the super max has worked in a couple of
occasions specifically for damien
lillard
that captured him in portland he stayed
it did not work for kawhi leonard it did
not work for anthony davis
and so had this been the third one in a
row where it didn't work i do think it
was going to be in peril
now if you watch the way teams operated
in the off season
you could definitely clearly see teams
hedging
the dallas mavericks made moves to make
sure that they could have cap space to
sign giannis
the miami heat signed a bunch of players
to one-year contracts
so that they could open up space the
toronto raptors
gave this contract to fred van vliet
that looked like
you know a valley and mountain it was it
started off high and the next year
dips down to allow for more cap space to
sign giannis
and goes back up um the new york knicks
didn't spend their money
um to make sure that they had a a spot
open for him so
um now those teams do have to move on it
was kind of like a poker game they had
all sort of put their chips in the
center
yes the ante now they're going to have
to to look at their other options and
like i said maybe it includes james
harden
maybe they wait and see what happens
with bradley beal who is sort of the
next
star player teams are keeping an eye on
maybe
you go down and look farther down the
list but certainly
giannis committing was not seen as good
news for a lot of teams especially in
those types of markets
in the last 24 hours and since we
haven't seen something like this as you
said in the modern nba i'm assuming we
should
also i i i using assuming
assuming that we should also not expect
giannis to
force his way out because he doesn't
like what's happening so early on in his
contract right like we
we should well that's a reality that
exists you know you know it's just like
in the entertainment business
and we're seeing it with hard and we've
seen it over and over a contract is over
when the talent says it's over
um now there is there is a one year
is built into the super max you can't
trade a player for one year so
the bucks are safe for this year you're
not allowed to trade them
uh until uh next season um
they're they're certainly not on out of
the uh the pressure cooker you know if
they don't
continue to to spend and one of the
things that they had to make clear to be
honest is look
we're going to spend into the luxury tax
and it's going to be an expensive team
because
keeping drew holiday is probably going
to cost them in the neighborhood of 30
million
a year uh for a supporting player
they're already playing chris middleton
30 million dollars a year so they're
going to be a very expensive team
um but they need to they definitely need
to do that but one of the reasons why
this was such an incredible
thing for them is even if giannis comes
to them
in two years and is not happy with the
way they're going and
expresses an interest in leaving he will
be on a long-term contract and they will
be able to get a king's reward for them
uh and you know they will not get a
player like giannis in all likelihood
but they will be able to protect their
franchise
um if he walks away next summer you have
a nuclear wasteland so you know nobody
wants to talk about that in milwaukee
right now and they shouldn't be talking
about that but that was definitely part
of the calculus when they
when they talked about this deal well
and again i i i before i let you go here
brian it's this has just been great to
just get lost in
all of the uh contractual drama and free
agency drama
and you know james harden and so on and
so forth i'm just thankful for hardin he
didn't apparently pick up
covert you know uh partying in in vegas
and
and i'm sure the nba is not terribly
thrilled to see
you know one of their bold-faced name
players on instagram
basically flouting everything like that
uh on the advance of a season where
there's no bubble
so what is the what is the plan here for
the nba
on on actually to go through a season
where they're a contact sport
indoors i mean this is this is uh
unprecedented where we're about to see
at least
with the nfl and college football
they're outdoors we're already getting a
glimpse
of how odd it looks with college
basketball uh how is the nba approaching
this
ryan well let me give you the official
answer and then i'll give you sort of
the reality yeah
the official answer is that the mba
believes that it has
very robust testing way better testing
than the nfl it's easier because it's a
smaller group
and they think that uh that they will be
able to
testing to protect uh now the schedule
is kind of preposterous to me because
they are still committed
to playing uh 30 inter-conference games
which means
teams starting in january are going to
be going on six game road trips
uh in and out of six hotels uh on and
off their planes
six times in six different cities i mean
i don't see
but you know here's here's a realistic
answer there's probably going to be
some disco some discontinue it and
discontinuing
because um the most important thing for
the nba was really to get started
christmas week
and even if they have some disruption in
january or february before the vaccine
can potentially arrive for nba players
uh whatever that may be whether that's
february or march we don't know
the back half of their season the
vaccine they're hoping is going to save
it
uh you know getting that start on
christmas week
is extraordinarily important financially
that's why they forced it
here's the other thing that nobody will
talk about the nba has already announced
over a hundred players
have tested positive for covid both in
uh
in the restart last summer and in the
start this year
in talking to to agents and talking to
trainers and talking to people with
teams
that number could actually be two or
three times higher in
actuality so many more players have had
this
and recovered from it and have some
level of antibodies
there may already be a partial way to
hurt immunity
in the league some people have said they
think it's 40 or so
wow now i'm going to be very very
careful with the next thing that i say
sure okay some players
who have already had the virus
may be operating with a level of freedom
that surprises people but because
they've had the virus
they know that they're not as much in
danger and it may be surprising what is
seen on social media
okay and that's why the nba is going to
be tested here
because they have put down these laws
and said no nightclubs
no uh no restaurants that are not on our
list etc
but yet here we have james harden who
we've just
just talked about how the rockets like
get away with all this stuff
here's james harden obviously in
nightclubs here's james harden
obviously not doing his media you know
kyrie irving got a lot of attention
james harden has not spoken to the press
yet
there was a game last night he still
hasn't spoken to the press he's in
flagrant violation of the nba's media
rules he has not been fined for that yet
there's been no fine
sent down whatsoever doesn't mean he
won't be at some point
but you know they put out they put out
this they put out the new rules that
you're not allowed to go in nightclubs
and the next two nights james hardens
and nightclubs
that is going to be a challenge for the
nba for the players
who have the antibodies what sort of
example are they going to set for their
teammates and
and publicly as that goes forward and i
hope that they're right that uh
that you know that having had it before
does actually prevent you from getting
it again because the one thing we know
about this virus is you think you know
one thing about it then you read
something completely counter and it's
very confusing and
i just hope there's in fact that light
at the end of the tunnel brian you
always make me smarter i love our chats
thanks for the time
greatly appreciate it let's chat down
the line you got it thank you that's
brian windhorst at windhorst espn on
both twitter and instagram
i truly love our i i say it every time
i'm like a broken record when he's on
he truly makes me smarter he knows what
he's talking about
he knows what he's talking about hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here